hey youtubers is Charlie so a lot of you
guys requested in Arthur Dayne video so
this is going to be a little bit about
the history of house Dayne but mostly
focusing on Arthur Danes life up to
Robert's rebellion he's not a character
that's alive on the show right now and
we haven't even really seen that much
from house Dayne but he's one of those
characters that just ties a lot of
things together a lot of historical
events and a lot of stuff that's going
on in present day so this hope that the
TV show might do his character in some
way most of the times when we hear about
him it's when characters are talking
about him in past tense like Catelyn
Stark or Jaime Lannister Jaime Lannister
almost worships the ground that he
walked on because when he first joined
the Kingsguard Arthur Dayne is the one
that taught him to fight
so if Jaime Lannister was like one of
the best swordsmen in the realm you know
before he lost his sword hand then
Arthur Dayne is that much better so not
only does the fandom hype him up
other characters inside the narrative
hype him up but just going back into the
history of how staying first just to add
some context the legend goes that 10,000
years ago a first meant the creator of
house Dayne saw a meteor fall to earth
near the torrenting River here used it
to forge their ancestral blade called
dawn and built Starfall their ancestral
home on the site their family ruled over
that area for thousands of years till
Nymeria swore about 700 BC that's the
10,000 ships when Queen Amira brought
her people in conquered Dorne house
Dayne was defeated in there after they
were bound to service to the Martel's
for history buffs Queen Ameria took a
Dane for her third husband but the
reason that house Martell went on to
rule Dorne is because her oldest
daughter succeeded her and she was born
of a Martell but even though the Danes
are bannermen
to house Martell there's still a
legendary house they go all the way back
to the First Men all the way back to the
building of the wall because of that
they actually they look like the rest of
the people in Westeros just very pale
skin the show is plays it fast and loose
with the way characters look depending
on which area they're from but the
rhoynish people generally looked like
this really the biggest thing that
people talk about when they talk about
Arthur Dayne is his sword his title is
sword of the morning it's part of their
family's tradition that they passed the
sword down to the most worthy person
it's a lot like Thor's hammer
let he who be worthy will displayed not
a lot is known about the meteorite metal
that the blade is made of only only is
just as strong as Valyrian steel but
it's a completely different metal
currently in the story there's no one
wielding the blade it just it resides at
their family's home of Starfall Ned
Stark took it there after Arthur Dayne
died during Robert's rebellion there are
other Danes that are alive right now but
no one is building it because none of
them have been deemed worthy
Eirik Dayne is the current lord of the
house but he's only about 12 years old
he's another character that we haven't
seen on the show yet but in the books
he's part of the Brotherhood without
banners so if he would have been on the
show we would have seen him whenever
Arya ran into them they're really two
big events in arthur danes life that are
significant to what's been going on on
the show so far there's a smiling knight
which is a big event in Jaime
Lannister's personal history and then
there's the Tower of joy which is a huge
nexus for rumors but is like a big
personal event in Ned Stark's history
the smiling net is a really infamous
outlaw that Jamie calls the mountain of
his youth so when you think of the
smiling Knight just think of Franken
Mountain here the knight was causing all
kinds of trouble
so the Kingsguard were ordered to put
him down you see how events in history
repeat themselves a little bit so Jamie
almost got his head squished like a
grape
just like Oberyn Martell did Arthur
Dayne rides in saves him then defeats
the smiling knight in the sword fight so
when you picture Arthur Dayne think of
someone so badass with a sword that they
could take Franken Mountain down the
Tower of joy incident happened years
after that that was during Robert's
rebellion towards the end of that so as
a Kingsguard Arthur Dayne became a
really close personal friend like the
closest friend of Rhaegar Targaryen
so regardless of regards actions or his
motives for capturing Lyanna Stark
Arthur followed him around protecting
him everywhere and when Rhaegar was
called away to lead the mad Kings forces
at the Trident
he left Arthur Dayne behind at the Tower
of joy to protect Lyanna Stark Ned Stark
and Howland Reed found out she was there
went to rescue her ended up killing
Arthur Dayne Ned Stark killed Arthur
Dayne and they found Liana dying
surrounded by her own blood this
sequence of events sets the stage for a
lot of like that the Jon Snow's mother
tinfoil theories I've already done a
video on lyanna stark's I'll put a link
for it in the description if you want to
learn more about that but even though he
ended up killing him Ned
starke still called Arthur Dayne the
finest knight that he ever knew he was
just a legendary Knight with a legendary
sword currently the TV show is trying to
cast a character for season six that
meets his description but that it's not
confirmed like we don't know that
they're doing Arthur Dayne it just says
that the actor they're looking for is a
legendary Knight with a legendary sword
and in real life the actor that they
cast needs to be amazing with a sword so
presumably whoever they cast is going to
be doing some really badass sword
fighting with a really legendary sword
whether or not it's in a flashback we
have no idea so the hope is is that
they'll announce who this character is
at comic-con but because Comic Con is
happening a couple weeks earlier this
year it's possible that they haven't
found any of these actors yet usually
Game of Thrones shows off a casting reel
every year at Comic Con like here the
five or six big characters that we've
cast so everybody cross their fingers
that we find out who like the big five
or six new people are my big question
for you is do you think that they're
casting Arthur Dayne and do you think
that we'll ever see his legendary sword
dawn on the show one way or the other
we're gonna find out by next Friday
that's when the Game of Thrones panel is
going to be I'm gonna do like a separate
comic-con preview for Game of Thrones
where I'll explain like who they're
bringing you know what's going to be
going on when I'm going to be posting
those videos I'll record the panel and
if they do release any kind of trailer
or anything like that I'll totally do
videos for that too so be sure to
subscribe to get everything I'll be I'll
be doing a giveaway during that week but
because I'm not going to do a Q&A
tomorrow because I'm doing the the Comic
Con preview instead I'll announce this
week's winner right now so
congratulations to Zell at you and a $20
Amazon gift card just be sure to private
message me on my channel so I can get
your contact info just for reference I'm
going to be doing a bunch of giveaways
next week most of the videos I post will
be comic-con related so I'll make a
special Comic Con playlist on my home
page it's gonna go all the way from
Wednesday to Sunday so there'll be about
like 14 or 15 videos that I should be
posting from that my Game of Thrones
explainer should post by Tuesday so just
keep your eyes peeled for that while you
guys wait for all the madness to start
all those videos to post you can click
here to learn all about resurrection in
the Song of Ice and Fire
and you can click here to learn all
about house Tyrell thank you so much for
watching everybody let's high five I'll
see you guys tonight
you